Our first guest tonight
is an Academy Award-winning
actress you know from films
such as "The Danish Girl,"
"Tomb Raider," and "Ex Machina."
She stars next in "The Glorias,"
which will be released
on September 30th
on Amazon Prime Video
and Digital.
Let's take a look.
-This year, the press
has finally discovered
a movement that has already been
strong for several years now,
and reported it
as a small, privileged,
rather lunatic event,
instead of a major evolution
in consciousness.
-Everyone's consciousness, male
and female, black and white.
This is the year
of women's liberation!
-Please welcome back to the show
Alicia Vikander.
How are you?
-I'm good.
Thank you for having me.
-It's wonderful
to see you again.
Very good Gloria Steinem voice.
I have to give you
full credit there.
That was very impressive.
-[Deep voice] Yeah, I had to --
I mean, I do have a low voice.
[Normal voice, laughing]
But I had to go even lower.
-Yeah.
-This is a wonderful film
where different actors
play Gloria Steinem
over the course of her life
based on a book
she wrote about her life.
And you and Julianne Moore
actually got to meet her.
I was lucky enough
to have her on this show.
I mean, she is a titan,
and it's very --
I was nervous talking to her.
Were you even more nervous
knowing that you then
had to take on
the task of playing her?
-Yeah, I was.
It was almost like --
I had this question asked
to me just earlier today --
"Oh, how was it meeting her
the first time?"
And I suddenly remembered,
I did actually meet her
for lunch first
before we met for rehearsals.
But I think I had almost
had that as a blank
because I was probably
so nervous.
I was just so kind of --
you know, felt so privileged
and honored
to just be able to meet her.
And, of course,
I managed to be a bit more calm
when she saw me, Julianne,
and Julie, our director,
for rehearsals,
which she was so generous
to tell me
that she could be part of.
I think it was, yeah,
quite a few times
when Julianne and I
just looked at one another,
couldn't really believe
what was happening.
But Gloria, she was --
she's so incredibly generous,
and she kind of
pushed us and said,
"You know, please,
just ask me anything."
And in the end, we actually --
I was a bit embarrassed to ask,
but she actually read
some of the scenes
from the script herself,
as herself,
which was pretty mind-blowing.
I even --
I actually have some videos
still on my iPhone,
which is a bit of a treasure.
-That's an incredible
advantage you got.
When I used to have to do
impressions on
"Saturday Night Live,"
I'd have to record it off the TV
to actually get the person
to do it for you.
-Yeah, I mean,
it was one of those things.
I was like, "Is it okay?
Can I film you doing this?"
And she was like,
"Yeah, of course."
And, you know,
we ended up getting like,
I don't know, 20 videos.
And I think, in the end,
I think she kind of enjoyed it,
but it was -- We each
kind of started the scenes,
and then she was like --
stopped halfway.
And then she was like,
"Well, actually
what happened at that event,"
or, "Actually what I did say
or what that person said."
And then it would always
turn out
to a much longer,
exciting story.
-That is fantastic.
You know, I think
the interesting thing
about Gloria's life
is she's always been timely,
and yet it seems
more timely than ever
to be making this movie now.
You guys must have been aware of
that while you were making it.
-Of course.
I mean, a lot of the discussions
that we had whilst filming
was how excited we were,
you know,
for the release of the film
and, of course, the topics
that it brings up.
And the fact that Gloria,
you know,
from the beginning
has been so supportive
and wanted to be part of us
releasing this film.
And we had big plans,
so, you know,
hoping to be on tour now
and be on a bus and involve,
you know, a lot of other women,
do a lot of talking circles,
which is something
that Gloria does a lot of.
Now, of course, the world
looks very different,
but it was a very beautiful
kind of communal feel
that we got a few weeks ago
when we --
I think we were, like,
16 women on a Zoom call.
Gloria was one of them.
We kind of passed around,
you know, the questions
of "What can you do?"
And everyone had
their own ideas of how --
how we can kind of
get the message out.
-It's --
You talk about how hard it is
to have those communal moments,
but I have heard
that one solution
you have to the dinner party
that we can no longer have
is to order the same take-out
as the people
that you Zoom with.
This is a very, very novel idea.
-It started
as something I did --
you know, like, a sneaky thing
I can -- you know, to a friend,
I can kind of sent
a text and like --
It happened once when
my friend was stateside,
so it was, like, a Sunday.
So it ended up
being a dinner for me
and a brunch for my friend.
And I was like,
"Yeah, this is an address.
You need to be there
in half an hour."
And then I had
just called, like, another --
I think it was
a Mexican restaurant.
And the good thing is,
like, Mexican food, you know,
you can kind of decide to order
the same thing wherever you are.
So then we ended up having
the exact same, you know, order,
and I think we even had
the same bottle of wine.
And then, you know,
that's a great way
of really forgetting
about the fact that you are
in front of a screen.
The tough thing is, though,
because if you've had
a few glasses of wine,
suddenly you have
this amazing social event --
Suddenly you just, like,
go offline,
and then you feel really lonely.
-[Fingers snap]
-Suddenly, everything's gone.
-Right, and then nobody
believes you when you say,
"Look, I was at dinner
with a friend."
They're like, "Were you?"
You -- I want
to congratulate you,
as well, 'cause you got this
in right under the wire.
You got your driver's license
in the UK.
-I did!
I mean, literally a few days
before lockdown.
I mean, it's been --
It's been way too -- too long.
I promised myself I was
going to do it before 30,
but that didn't happen.
But now I have it, and,
you know, I was born in Sweden,
which drive on the right side,
so for me to have passed
the test in the UK,
in London, too,
with all the black cabs,
and everything
and on the left side,
I feel like I'm hopefully
not a huge danger
when I go out there
in the traffic.
-I think the good news is,
no matter
how bad a driver you are,
there are so many
other huge dangers
right now that you're so --
you're comfortably
at the bottom of the list.
-People will forget
if I just run over them.
-Yeah, if you sideswipe
somebody right now,
that's the least
of their problems.
And it's really good now
I think, more than ever,
a good time
to be able to get in a car
and drive as fast as possible.
So congratulations
on your license.
Congratulations, as well,
on the film.
It's always so nice to see you.
-So good to see you.
Thank you so much.